翻訳: Kiyokazu Konishi
校正: Yuri Ueda
図書館へ行きますとね
高齢者が たくさんいるんですわ
こう 新聞を見とるんですね
新聞見とるのか 寝とるのか
よく分からんです
（笑）
ある日 知り合いが いたもんですから
「何しとるの？」って 聞いたんですね
「実はね ウチに居ると カミさんが
粗大ゴミ扱いだわ」（笑）
と言うことは 現場から 逃げとる
ということなんですね
何かつまらん ですね
もっともっと 高齢者が 社会に向けて
少しでも 社会に役に立つことを
努力 したいですね
ところで 今の社会って 非常にいいですね
高齢者を 大事にしてくれて
施設はあるし 言うことないと思うんです
そういうサービスを受けとるのが
当たり前に なっちゃっとるんですね 今
当たり前には 感謝ができないです なかなか
そういったことで 何らかの形で
そういうサービスを受けた時に
社会に対して
どうお返しを していくか
ということを考えないと
高齢者の集まりばっかりに なっちゃうんですね
そういうことを考えると もっともっと
地域にやれることは あると思うんですね
自分で 今まで
いろんな経験をしてみえた方
ばかりですので
その経験を活かして 社会に貢献できたら
という風に 常々思っております
でも 中にはね この社会活動に入っていくと
「オレこんなことをやっとる」 と
こう胸を張っちゃう人が みえるんですね
自慢なんですわ
自慢も あんまりすると
みっともないですので
自慢をせずに こう自然体で
特別なことをやっとる訳ではないですので
自然体で 活動したいですね
ちょっとここで 私のことをお話します
昭和10年 安城で生まれ 安城で育ちました
今年ね 80なんですわ
80が 活動の終点じゃないですので
自分の生きられる道を考えて
これから生きたいと思っています
私は 10才の時に三河地震―
三河地震を経験した人は
おられんと思いますが―
三河地震を 10才の時に経験しております
これがまた 冬の寒い日でね
真っ暗闇 なんですわ
だいたい 電気がそうたくさんあった
わけじゃないですけど
暗闇の中で 父親が「外にでろ！」っていう
合図の下に出ようと思っても
戸が開かんですね
敷居から外れちゃって
そんな 苦い経験をしております
三河地震が終わって
８月に終戦なんですね
終戦の時は 一応 戦争は
終止符を打たれたんですけど
戦争の時が また大変なんですわ
物資が無くて
物は無い お金は無い
終戦は 貧乏で 大変な時期を
子どもごころに 覚えております
そんな時代を過ぎて
中学の２年生ぐらいだったと記憶していますけど
通学路に 町工場があるんですわ
鉄工場が
鉄工場に
みなさん旋盤っていう機械を
見られたことはありますかね
これですね
材料を固定して 回転させて
刃物で削るんです
で 思うものを作るんですね
これがね
もう 何か知らないけれど 好きでね
こうやって 窓越しに その町工場を
ずーっと 見とった記憶があります
それがまあ 不思議で仕方なかったですね
鉄で鉄を削る 鉄の上を鉄が走る
これがもうほんとに
不思議でならんかった訳です
また 作業をしている人がカッコ良くてね
もう ホレこんじゃっておったんですけど
大人になったら 旋盤工になるって
そこでもう決めちゃったんです
中学２年の時に
中学を出て
地元の電動工具メーカーに 入社しました
また 入社した時に 大体 生意気 ですわね
「僕 旋盤がやりたい！」って
面接官に言っちゃんたんです
そんな 中学出の若造が
今からお世話になる 会社の上司に向かって
自分の気持ちを 伝えようということを
したって言うことは
大体ムチャな話なんですわ
だけど 結果は
旋盤の職場に 配属されました
それが 仕事の最初なんですね
それから20年ほど経つとね
また不思議でね これが
思うものが 思うように 加工できちゃうんです
それと 特別な教育を受けること無しに
先輩の後ろ姿で 技術を盗んで
自分のものにした 経験があります
当時は 非常に 先輩後輩の上下関係が
非常にうるさくて
嫌な雰囲気なんですけど
もう嫌だって 言っとれんですね
もう 自分で努力しかない と思って
真剣に取り組んだんです
ほんとに 厳しかったですね
だけどね また楽しいんですわ
自分の思ったものが思うように
加工できちゃうんですから
ま そんな時期で あった訳ですけれども
退職して 地元へ帰るんですね
それで そのままじっとしとりゃ
じっとしとって終わり なんです
その時にあるきっかけで
防災活動に 参加するようになりました
そこで 10才の頃に体験した
三河地震 のことを思い出して
みなさんに 防災の 啓発活動を
ずっとやっとったんですけれども
案外ね 東北の話だとか
神戸の話になっちゃうんですね
安城は 安泰 ですわ
こんな状況でしたが
東海地震が 間もなく来ると言うことは
みなさんご存知ですね
そういった中でも
なかなか真剣に取り組めなかったんです
「地震が来る来る と言って
いろいろ騒いでいるけど
来えへんじゃん」 とこうくる訳ですね
地震が来てからでは 遅いんですわ
訓練ていうのは
そういうことをしっかり踏まえて
行きたいな ということで
啓発活動を 今も続けているんですけど
そんな仲間がね ある日ね 突然
突然ですよ
「こういうものがあるといいね」 って言ったのが
結果として これなんですわ
僕が 「うん できるよ」って
また 簡単に言っちゃうんですね
だいたい 人がいいですので
（笑）
簡単に答えてから
大体ね 簡単 に答えて言うと 後で悩むんですわ
（笑）
「あーあんなこと言うんでは無かった」
僕は 全然悩まんですね
ちょっと ここの関係もあるけどね
（笑）
その時に 「うん できるよ」 って言った時に
もうすでに アイデアを 具現化してしまうと言う
回転はあったんですね
こういう状態なら できるよってことで
返事をした訳ですけども
これですね
これが本体の心臓部です
ここに ４ヶ所に 鋼球を設置して
電動ドリルで ベルトを回して
プーリーを２ヶ 回します
これと プーリーは 偏心量が
20ミリの偏心量で 同期しとるんですね
同期しないと どこかでロック
しちゃいますから
同期するように作りました
これも 全然 悩んだことは無いです
なぜ鋼球にしたかというと
大体 動くものは 摩擦抵抗が
あるんですね
摩擦抵抗を 極限まで下げないと
モーターに 負担がきちゃうんですね
それで いま
この上に 人が乗る台を
こう 載せる訳ですね
そうして 揺らすんです
揺らすのも その振幅っていうのが
あるんですね
揺れる 距離です
距離は 40ミリの振幅で １秒間に３回揺らす
これが 一般に聞く 震度５ なんですね
大型の地震体験装置は
愛知県にも 今 ２台あるんですけど
これが 県に２台しか ないんです
借りたくても なかなか 順番 来ないですね
順番が来ないものを
無いモノねだりしとっても しょうがないんで
じゃあ 作ろうってことで
スタートした訳ですけれども
これは（1台の購入価格は）3000万 ですわ
一方 僕が開発したこれはね
40万です
こんなことで
100倍ほどの差がある訳ですけど
機能は円弧ですので
ＸＹで動く 大型の体験装置とは 動きが
ちょっと違いますけど
震度６強まで 出ます
三河地震の大きさ 震度６強まで
出すことができます
こういったアイデアを 即 イメージして
「できるよ」って言っていうのを 45年間
モノづくりに 没頭してきたことが
非常に 参考になっているのかなって
いうふうに 思っております
今ね 今ですよ
退職すると 時間があるんですわ 時間が
金は無いですよ（笑）
時間があるんですね
ボランティア活動を
ずっとしとるんですけど
お金を使うばっかりが
ボランティアではないんですね
お金が無くても 工夫ひとつで
こういった 体験装置が出来るってことを
みなさんに ちょっと 紹介しながら
実際に動かしてみます
この中で 体験したい人
あのね 機械がね
女性を好むんですわ（笑）
はい どうぞ
一回 体験してみてください
（拍手）
（装置の作動音）
（作動音が上がる）
（補助者）「今 震度５です」
（補助者）「今 ６弱になりました」
（作動音がさらに上がる）
これが来るんですよ あの 南海トラフはずっと
（作動音停止）
（補助者） 「最後は震度７になりました」
（笑）
（拍手）
あの 彼はね震度を
スピードのように やるんですわ（笑）
はい どうも ありがとうございました（拍手）
ちょっと あの 感想を聞いてみます
楽しかったか 怖かったか どちらですか？
（女性） 「両方」
（笑）
両方ね
大体ね 中学生も
400人以上体験しとるんですけど
怖かった人はね １割ないですね
楽しかった（笑）
そりゃ 中学生は こういう遊具だったら
100円 入れなきゃ いかん ですのでね
（笑）
それで 楽しく
我々の 本来の体験というのは
楽しんで 楽しんで
その時に こんなことで楽しんだ
ということが 頭に残っていますから
自分の 身体で憶えちゃっていますから
そういうのを思い起こして
地域の防災活動に
極力 参加をして
頂きたいと 思っております
今 乗って頂いた方にも
半々だよ って言われたんですけど
震度６強というのは 大変なんですね
震度６強が 家庭で起きた時に
特に ご婦人の方は
ガスを使っていますので
その辺も考慮しながら
これから 防災活動に
ちょっと 目を向けて頂くと
有難いなあ と思っております
私は 特別なことは やれませんけど
今まで培って来た
経験を少しでも
地域に役に立ててもらいたい ということで
こういった啓発活動を やって来たんですし
今後も続けて行きたい と思っております
無理しなくていいんですわ
自然体で
世の中の役に立つことを
高齢者が 一人ずつが 一点やればね
そうすれば 日本は
高齢者が施設で恩恵受けるよりよほど
お金かからんでいい と思うんですね
そうして見ると 退職した時がね
自分の人生の
分岐点じゃないのかな ということを
常々 思っております
これが 分岐点 てのは 社会に役立つのか
日向ぼっこで 丹前着ておったら
いいのかって 部分ですね
それを この装置を作った時に感じました
みなさん 今までお話したことは
こういう生き方をしている
80のお爺が 安城にいるよ って ことです
このことを含めて みなさん如何ですかね？
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
やっぱり 若さには勝てんですね
みなさんに持ち上げて頂いて
今日は 無事終わることができました
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）